- You were just in
Miami, but you were also
recently honored in Miami, right?
- I was, I was.
- Yeah, how was that?
- I was honored with my, with a statue.
- [Kelly] I know, so that's crazy.
- [Dwayne] Yes, thank you.
- It's a bronze statue of you.
Did you have any input on
this statue, by the way?
- I do, I do.
- Oh okay.
- I knew before the audience knew.
I had to sit down with the Heat.
But, it was great to share it
in Miami with the audience,
with the fan base that's been there.
Like that statue is all of our statue.
Like all are invested into
Miami putting that statue up,
and so the fact that it's
gonna happen later this year,
it's gonna be pretty cool, so...
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
Of course I'm excited and all the things,
but it's kinda weird too, like-
- There's a statue, yeah.
- Who thinks you,
where's the statue?
- I don't know, it's,
not many people have one.
- Right, yeah like I know like monuments,
I don't know like, you know like...
I'm alive and so...
- I'm alive.
(audience laughing)
- You know what I mean?
- I am not dead yet.
- No, like normally when
you think of monuments,-
- I'm alive, so-
- And I'm like 42 and I'm like wow,
I'm getting a statue?
Like, I feel like I should be older
in my life.
- I feel like
every time you go to Miami, though,
you have to take a picture with it.
- Oh I will.
- 'Cause you are alive, so-
- Well, I told them,
like I was askin' them
like what are people, what are you guys
gonna do at nighttime
when people wanna come
and enjoy themselves by my statue?
- Yeah, light it up.
(crowd laughs)
- Yeah, and they was like
well we may have security, may not.
I was like, well, I'm
talking about myself.
Like, I may come at
like two in the morning
and like...
(crowd laughs)
- And be like damn, I got a statue.
- Yeah, bring my music
and do my TikToks in
front of my own statue.
- Exactly, or your podcast.
- Or my podcast, do that out there.
- Here's the why, I got a statue.
Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
(hands smack)
- Welcome to the why.
- Yeah welcome to the why.
- They why, right behind me.
- I got a statue. I want a statue.